for me you know I have a higher power
and and I want to be able to
you know to access that higher power
better and it's all up to me being
willing to let go of control and so it's
a constant battle because I want to be
in control you know that's my ego
you know I want to run the show but it
feels nice to let it go man you know
it's like having one of those you know
those electric things that clean clean
your pool or clean your floor
you know you can leave you can leave and
go do whatever you can be gone and that
thing's still working
you know and that's something
um that I think is pretty powerful
you know just to know that there can be
something out there that has your back
and that's Brave it's Brave to not
uh it's Brave to not get stuck in your
own loneliness